[Music]
not a lot of people know this but you
had brain surgery yes so you had a brain
and arterial venous malformation which
is a malformation of veins and arteries
in your brain sometimes it's inside your
brain deep other times it's on the
exterior which was in my right frontal
lobe and so it hemorrhaged for a little
while and while I was filming Yogi Berra
3d the greatest piece of talking Berra
said that existed you know because there
was overactive in my brain I began to
actually go insane which is a very
interesting experience because you don't
realize that you're going crazy
all the while traveling into the forest
to speak with bears that don't exist
people would hold up ping-pong balls at
the end of a stick and you would start
talking to that eye line and they take
them away and it's just a crazy man in
New Zealand in a crazy forest talking to
two cartoon characters that aren't there
literally looking off into space being
like well booboo where's Yogi and they'd
be like Boo Boo's the shorter one he's
down here look lower and I'm like okay
where's yogi yes it's quite a thing then
I returned had a series of seizures yeah
and woke up at cedars-sinai hospital and
then a robot wheeled into the room like
a it looked like it's a Segway with a
sort of Center like peace and then a
flat-screen television with a human's
face being like Skyped in web chat saw
and it came in and it wheels in and it
missed hi
this guy's like hello I'm your doctor
but I'm in Germany right now and I swear
to God under my breath I just when early
in the future
how far away in the future the guys like
now we're not in the future I'll be back
tomorrow like he heard it before yeah
like he was like another future guy the
future and technology exists now you've
only been out for 24 hours I'll see you
tomorrow and they just flew away but the
weirdest moment was after he explained
what's happened as he turn around a
wheeled out the nurse joined him and I
remember seeing the back of this robot
walking and this woman walking way into
this long corridor with light dappling
in mostly darkness and the nurse said
something to the robot and the screen I
could say for me I turned it it went
like this
and when it turned back I just I
remember wondering I was like we are in
the future but this is how they ease
people into it oh my god you know it was
a it was a pretty weird experience while
I was there when you left for the
surgery that's right and I tell
everybody cuz I love spending the Paul
Bunyan desk tales about you
I'm not joking there's nothing really
funny about it I was like if that were
me I would have been like really Schick
and and shaken and you looked like you
were about to go to Arby's for lunch
you're like that see which is you know a
little a little scared yeah a little
scared we don't know quite what's gonna
end up happening but we know it's gonna
be delicious
[Music]